we begin in china where the
international monetary fund has warned
of an unbalanced recovery
the organization forecasts the world's
second largest economy will grow 4.8
this year that's down from 8.1
last year the imf criticized beijing's
regulatory crackdowns against tech
giants saying such measures could scare
off foreign investment
the ailing real estate sector is another
concern mentioned in the report
speaking of which beijing is considering
breaking up the teetering real estate
giant evergrant that's according to a
new report from bloomberg
the proposal said to come from officials
in evergrand's home profits of guangdong
calls for the developer to sell off most
assets
a green light from beijing would kick
off a lengthy unwinding of the company
and likely provoke a battle over which
creditors get paid first
evergrand defaulted on debt for the
first time in december and has asked its
creditors for patience as it works out a
plan
fraser howe is a china analyst and an
author he joins me from singapore fraser
thank you very much for joining us i
want to begin by talking about the
current state of things in china we look
at the city of xiong on i believe it's
about 1.2 million people from reading it
right
it's been locked down completely because
of china's zero coveted policy
what effect has that zero covered policy
had on the local economy and then what
is it having on the world economy can we
say yet
uh well we we know how our lockdowns
work for the economy it's not good and
china now with omicron although the
numbers are tiny in comparison but in
germany or elsewhere in europe um these
sort of spot lockdowns are hugely
problematic they're having knock-on
effects across the economy it saps
confidence and i think it's a worrying
sign for the chinese leadership going
forward that you know six months ago
they felt they were on top of uh delta
they felt they were on top of
the the pandemic and they could sort of
you know carry along quite happily but
now clearly things are very different
when asked about evergrand you know
overseas creditors are becoming
impatient with the company they've
threatened legal action the company says
it needs months to come up with a plan
where's this all headed
um well it's going badly you know the
fact that it's default it tells you
everything you need to know about it
basically evergrande is something like
300 billion dollars that's in direct
debts through bonds to foreigners and
domestic chinese but also a huge number
of suppliers within china so you're
talking about building companies
contractors you know
toilet manufacturers people who provide
all your stuff that you put in these
flats they've made commitments to them
they've built flats
and they haven't paid them or indeed
they've taken money from
uh investors and home buyers and they
haven't built the flats so it's all it's
going to take months and years
basically to solve evergreen's problems
that the model that we're using is
fundamentally broken and there is going
to be a lot of pain the question is do
you take that pain in a short term or do
you spread it out over multiple years
fraser just how concerned should we be
about the chinese economy right now and
how seriously are those concerns being
taken by the leadership
um i think the second part first i think
they're being taken very seriously but
at the same time you know the imf is
still saying 4.8 growth so again many
countries would be happy with 4.8 growth
so again i think we have to move away
from this idea that china's on the brink
of collapse what i think the the
pandemic has shown in whatever grants
and that we've shown is that china isn't
a medical economy and it's going there's
a long slog to get out of these problems
and especially with the pandemic as long
as it continues with its zero culvert
model then all that's doing is it's
basically taking its its workout time is
just increasing and is going to be these
problems are going to be with china for
many years to come
all right china analyst fraser hawaii
thank you very much
you